- The process though,
you came back to that.
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
- Well, actually, that's
actually what drew me
to asking him.
- Yeah.
- Because you, again, the
the longer you do this,
the more you realize how integral
those people are to making
it all happen, you know?
- My integral part is standing over there
and he's been with me since
American Idol for 20 years.
I've never done a tour without Jason.
(audience applauds and cheers)
Everybody, everybody, literally every.
and he produces, we write together.
Like, we're, like, the
best musical duo ever.
I love us.
But because we are different
and I think that's what's awesome.
We bring something different to the table.
And to have that stability
with someone in your career,
from that long ago,
and that you still gel,
and you still create with, is so...
it's rare.
- It's everything.
- It's rare and it's also everything.
Like, I don't know a lot of
people that have that, you know,
and I, literally, was just
telling somebody the other,
I was, like, I'm the luckiest person ever.
Like, people, like, my
career is also because of
that man standing over there.
Like, they help you
create, they bring out you,
they make you comfortable,
'cause you know them well enough.
Like, it's just the best
collaborative process.
I agree with that.
- Yeah, I'll agree with that.
But your career is because
of you, essentially,
is because of you-
- I just mean I have a
little bit to with it.
- [Seal] You and your talent, you know.
- I'm a little bit to do.
That's what he would say.
But no, I just mean, like,
but I do think that, you know,
starting out, even like
starting at how I did,
like, these other, you know,
artists and contestants on these shows,
it's, like, I love so
many different sounds.
So, to, kind of, drive home,
like, what I'm gonna focus on,
it's hard.
I'm ADHD, so he's been the
person to, kind of, be, like,
let's focus.
- I gotta ask you,
'cause I could never have
done what you what you did,
you know, in order to get to-
- I love competition.
(audience laughs)
- See, yeah, me too, me too,
but I just think it takes-
- Even with yourself,
competing with yourself.
- Yeah, but I just think
it takes a certain level
of courage and confidence
to be able to go on a show.
- Yeah.
- And break through that way.
I mean, I'm not, you know,
being modest or anything.
I could never have done that.
I know what I'm capable of when I-
- Which is hysterical, though,
because your voice is, like,
what people are looking for.
- I wouldn't have done it.
I wouldn't have.
It takes, I think, a
certain amount of courage
to put yourself out there.
- Yeah.
- And be judged in amongst
other people, right?
And be critiqued on a
show, on a world stage.
I don't know if anyone realizes
how hard that is, you know,
to actually put yourself out there,
and people tell you how good
you were or how bad you were,
and you having to take it, you
know, on a show like you did.
I wouldn't have had
the courage to do that.
And so, I have so much admiration.
- Well, thank you.
I think, though-
- But what was it like?
- It was like really
good bootcamp, though,
because it was really hard and
it was more hard, not for me,
but to watch other people.
I'm always that person, like,
it's hard for me to watch other
people go through something
and, like, other artists
were not handling it well,
like, what people would say online.
And it was the first time
the show was on, or whatever.
So, that was harder,
watching people, you know,
break their spirit a bit.
- Yeah.
- I think.
And that sucks.
But I will say, it was a great bootcamp,
because after that I felt like,
I mean, this industry is hard.
You say you couldn't handle it,
but you did, because this
industry is not easy.
Even if you're selling 8 million
albums, or doing whatever,
there's always people just
trying to knock you down
or say something just super (beeps)
I can't say that on TV, but-
(audience laughs)
- But you went from nothing
to all of a sudden being exposed.
- But that's the trick, though.
That's why I think that is the key.
When you have no home,
my place had burned down,
I was living in my car for a bit,
like, I had nothing, I had nothing.
And, I think, when you have nothing,
you have nothing to lose.
So, you just show up and
you go, sure, you can laugh.
But if I'm getting paid,
I'm laughing all the way to the bank,
so I'm, like... (laughs)
(Seal laughs and applauds)
(audience applauds and cheers)
Like, I think you don't...
At that point, like, in my mind,
literally, I didn't think
that it would go anywhere.
I mean, a lot of people don't
go anywhere on those shows.
You know what I'm saying?
You don't know.
And so I was, literally, just, like,
I need to pay my water bill.
I need to get housing.
I think when you're that
desperate, you don't...
All of that stuff is, like, I
don't even have time for that.
Like, these are real issues I have.
I think, when that is your...
That's why I think when everybody's,
like, they ask celebrities, like,
"Oh, do you want your
kid in the business?"
Which, I'm gonna ask, like,
"Would you really want your kid
to thrive in this kinda business?"
Because it's a hard one.
Sometimes I think my kids
will never know what it's like
to go without, to really
have that desperation,
of, like, having to push
yourself, and go for it.
And that's hard like to teach, you know.
I don't know if you can teach that.
- [Seal] It is hard.
So, then you don't want
them to swallow your kids up
in an industry that's hard.
I don't know, what are your thoughts?
Am I just dark, what?
(audience laughs)
- No, not at all.
'Cause I've often thought of that.
My son, Henry, he sings
and he has a great voice.
- Yeah.
- He doesn't think so
but he has a really great
husky voice, you know.
- But his dad is you, that's hard.
(audience laughs)
I'm just gonna say it.
- But then, you know, if
that's what he wanted to do.
- [Kelly] do it.
- It's my job to just support him
and as much as-
- Yeah.
- As much as I can.
I don't know, it's a tough one
because, obviously, you know,
we've traveled that road
and we know how difficult it can be.
But, ultimately, my advice
to them is just be happy.
- Yeah.
- Do whatever, I don't care if it's, like,
if you've gotta go and like
sweep the streets, you know,
or if you-
- Get one life, be happy
with what you're doing.
- Yeah, and just be happy.
'Cause I really believe
that is the point of it all.
- Yeah.
- Is to try and figure out how
to be as happy as possible.
Now, that sounds like a kind of, almost,
flippant thing to say and as-
- No, it's simple, but it's hard.
- It's really hard.
- Yeah.
- If you think about it, because...
Be happy and all that that entails.
Can I be happy if this person isn't happy
or if that person's suffering, you know.
- Yeah, or what society tells you,
you should be happy if you're not yet.
- Exactly, so if they, you know,
whatever they choose to
do, whether it's music,
whether it's...
My eldest daughter, Leni,
who was actually gonna be here today,
but she has to go back to New York.
She's modeling, and I know
that's a kind of, you know,
that's a...
- A hard game as well, yeah.
- Yeah, lots of rejection.
A hard road to...
And, you know, she has
a well-known mother.
- Never heard of her.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- But, as long as she's happy.
And, you know, and I will
say this, for the kids,
I can't call them kids anymore,
'cause they're teenagers,
they're young adults,
but for my sons and
daughters, I will say this,
they got it a lot more figured out
than I ever did at their age, you know.
- You've done a good job.
- I find that I spend way too
much time worrying about them
and, you know, if they'll find their way.
But the way that they see the world
is very different from the way
that we, as adults, see
the world, you know.
Where we see problems, they
see solutions and vice versa.
- Oh, I hope the younger
generation figures it out. (laughs)